I'm your leaders here hope you are good
I want to talk to you a little bit today
about mentoring what's the difference
between mentoring and coaching do you
need a mentor and if so what kind of a
mentor do I have a mentor and also give
you the two things that you need in
order to be super successful in any
business or walk of life so firstly do I
have a mentor the answer is a big fat
yes I think that unless you are the best
in the world in your field and know
absolutely everything there is to know
about that topic then you should have a
mentor and guess what I'm not the best
in the world at anything as far as I'm
aware so I have a mentor a property
mentor I still have a property mentor I
have a speaking mentor I have a business
mentor I have a marketing mentor I have
a whole lot of mentors I also have
coaches as well the difference between a
mentor and a coach is that a mentor is
someone that will give you information
so you'll come to them and you're asked
for advice kind of like a consultant I
coach is someone that will cheer you on
and say come on you can do this and hold
you accountable both are super important
personally I prefer mentors because I'm
a pretty self-motivated kind of guy and
my wife is my biggest cheerleader she
holds me accountable that's for sure so
I prefer mentors but you know it depends
on the person you might be for a coach
but you probably need both so yes I've
got mentors and I've been in property
for 10 years now so I do my stuff but
there's still some aspects to property
that I don't know lots about so I might
have a mentor who specifies in a
slightly different type of property so
for instance commercial property I know
a little bit about it but my expertise
lies in residential property so unless
you know everything about everything
you need a mentor in order to be
successful you need two things you need
one knowledge you've got to know what to
do and then two you've got to have
action and actually implement that
knowledge the two types of people that
concern me the most or when I might be
running a property crash course or an
event and I teach something really good
and the two reactions that you should
not have which broke people have and
unsuccessful people have want is Wow
I'm going to do that what a brilliant
idea and then
at home and you don't do it what do we
call those people we call those people
course junkies where you fill up with
knowledge you become like a stuffed
turkey and never actually do anything
and that's a very dangerous position to
be in the kind of person it's also broke
and unsuccessful that infuriates me just
as much as the person that doesn't
implement anything is the person who
says I already know that and they've
heard it before or they think they know
it but they're not doing it or guess
what if you don't do it then you don't
know it so the two things that you need
in order to be successful one is
knowledge and two is action
implementation if you can have the
knowledge and then have the discipline
and the courage to actually do it you're
going to fly in any field in any
business the next question when do you
stop needing a mentor when do you say
okay you know what
enough enough I am good but what I would
say is you stop needing a mentor when
you are the best in the world at that
subject and when you know everything
there is to know about that field which
is probably never and in fact if you
look at the people that do all the best
in the world
guess what they still have mentors and
coaches so yes you absolutely do need a
mentor mentor should work for free out
of the goodness of their heart let me
explain why that's baloney reason number
one is because even though your mentor
probably doesn't need the money they'll
take the money why because they know
that everything has to have a fair
exchange and if they train you for a
pittance to start the goodness of their
own heart then there's an imbalance in
the world it's just not it's just not
how life works so unless you're super
super lucky and you manage to have a
parent or a friend or a friend of a
friend who's happy to do it for free
then generally speaking wake up to the
real world if I'm looking for a mentor
I'm wanting to spend big bucks because I
know that that's what you get what you
pay for and if I'm going to spend my
time and energy with somebody learning
and squeezing information out of them I
want them to be absolutely freaking
awesome at their field and if I have to
pay big bucks
then I completely expect to do that and
the final question is do I mentor people
a lot of people email me all the time
asking if I can mentor them
not really I do that vary a little bit
but it's very selective
usually I have to know you first so
probably the best thing if you did want
to be mentor by me the best thing would
probably be to come down to one of my
programs meet me so hope that's been
helpful in conclusion get a good mentor
get good people around you learn from
the mentor and then do it and if you
haven't got the willpower to do it then
get a mentor and a coach god bless you
I'll see you soon